good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a gloomy and
dark day here in New York but the
morning toast is bright as ever because
there's so many exciting things we need
to talk about one Simon Huck is joining
us today which means we are one step
closer into getting a Kardashian on this
show too we have brand-new cameras so if
you're watching live on YouTube you are
now able to stream in 1080p
whatever that means we're really excited
about it we've got new lights we're
looking bright and tan and saturated and
we hope you're enjoying this premium
stream our furniture is almost here
we're just coming together yeah it's
really exciting that people will stop
complaining about something one thing on
the on the suggestion box list check
talked about your 1080p we hear you we
see you your valid complaints and we're
working on it
yeah so enjoy enjoy um very excited for
today's show much to discuss The
Bachelor was on last night three hours
of your life that you will never get
back and another 20 minutes on this show
recapping it and then the snatchler on
Thursday and of course we are going to
be you know diving deep into the Iowa
caucus because they ruin my night last
night not only did the bachelor take
three hours because they were supposed
to chime in did you get any ABC
interruptions no I didn't because I was
planning on watching starting at 9:00
because I thought the Iowa caucus was
gonna take up but then it turned out I
missed so much and then there were no
interruptions we're going deep into the
Iowa caucus and joke
because you know that they like didn't
choose a winner yeah it's like 12:00
it's been now like 24 hours and they
didn't figure out mpg budda judge said
that he won and like no he didn't I mean
it's anyone's game now I admire his
confidence though I realized you know I
won the twenty20 Iowa caucus all I know
is that most likely my favorite
candidate Andrew yang didn't win and we
will not be getting a four-day workweek
because he's the number one champion of
that in America you know it doesn't
matter who wins cuz we're losers I mean
it's just not he badly and reing on the
for I don't know any of us other policy
so I'm completely joking here but his
four-day workweek like he is definitely
ahead of his time and it's not his time
ya know but I think one day like will
look back at Andrew yang and be like wow
a visionary
I told completely agree okay cool well
that's or politics segment for today
yeah now you know everything you need to
know what else what did you last night I
walk I did SoulCycle musical Monday oh
yeah
um watch The Bachelor finished a book
and then I was getting a migraine but I
took a migraine pill and I woke up
feeling all right not great do you think
that you grind your teeth in your sleep
yes and that gives you a migraine yes I
will be actually getting night here's
the night guard yeah that's what you
need um I my dad just told me to do that
so I don't do like call and confirm that
that's what I want to do but I'm glad
that you also have the migraine pill to
help with that situation yes I
definitely am a grinder uh oh you were
you a great big grind lined ER back in
the day yeah I was right in the middle I
was actually started the grind line no
I'm just like not big on like people
touching like randomly yeah that's how
the coronavirus started the grind line
is gonna be a no for me okay
well I feel as though we have such a
busy day we have to recap The Bachelor
we have the Fast Five stories and we
have Simon I just want to jump right in
I know I know we're sitting here
lollygagging like a bunch of
lollygaggers yeah and I think that
that's a waste of people's time I agree
so without further ado it is time for
the Fast Five stories that you yes you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and
while that's definitely true and them of
course not here to embarrass you on your
own show and tell you that you're wrong
but you are wrong because it is time but
not until I let everyone know I'm so
embarrassed
are you embarrassed Otto yes I'm here to
let everyone know that today's episode
very she's not by the way yeah that was
a joke
very chic today's episode that's why we
both look very put together and glam is
because our episode we did want to be
embarrassed is brought to you by the
real real you can own iconic luxury
items at an unreal value with the real
real the leading reseller of
authenticated luxury consignment from
top designers like Louis Vuitton Gucci
Rolex LTA and hundreds more up to 90%
off retail you could both shop and
consign women's and men's luxury fashion
and street wear as well as jewelry
watches art and home the new arrivals
come in daily and every item undergoes
Nuria Brielle's meticulous
authentication process they employ over
a hundred brand specialist gemologist
horologist and art curators from around
the globe to make sure that every item
is authenticated
you can shop luxury that was sustainable
way so you don't have to feel bad about
spending at you know a little extra cash
on a new Gucci bag because it's
sustainable
you can shop online or download the app
or you can not visit one of their stores
in Soho West Hollywood or their newest
location at 870 Madison in New York and
if you're looking to consign make some
space in your closet for some new
investment pieces you can sell your
stuff on the real rail - they have White
Glove service for free in-home pickup
we both shop and consign and we just
can't recommend it enough this has been
truly a dream sponsor for our show
because the bag that I wore today it's
from the real real is anything else
no just my bag shop in store online or
download the app which is such a premium
experience and get 20% off select items
with the promo code real re al that's
the real real promo code real for 20%
off select items sign on look fly sign
on look fly add to your collection
become an investor at a fraction of the
price
yeah okay sartet stories they're
actually really fun really light and I'm
excited to just bounce around um you
know much more of like a sedentary
person so like bouncing is not really
for me but I'll let you do the bounce oh
my god you were asking me what I did
yesterday and it just totally escaped my
mind that I made a tick-tock
and I learned a new tick-tock dance by
the way I showed you that dance
no no not doja cat no I showed you the
Britney Spears dance at Olivia's house
you did yes at the Super Bowl you showed
it to me I didn't sitting down on the
couch I was very impressive I was like
oh man I miss it well oh my gosh you
guys the pretty best dance it's the best
dance but then I had to like change for
my tick-tock as I looked so nerdy in my
little dress from yesterday I looks like
a recital yeah and did appropriate on
tick-tock um it just wasn't and then I
was like oh it's Britney Spears hit me
one more time like I'm gonna put my hair
up but I just got like so crazy making
bass buns jeez Louise it was like an
answer to sweat
yeah because I did the video so many
times because I was like I can do it
better totally and you think you're a
good dancer you think you're a good
dancer and then you tick tock yeah but I
was pleased with how it came out like
there was a few minor things I would do
differently next time that's the beauty
of tik-tok you just keep on doing the
same [ __ ] dances it's just hard the
beauty the hard thing about tick-tock is
that you want to look cute so like more
often than not when I'm scrolling
tick-tock and have an idea to do one I
look like a wrap right maybe after the
show like an hour looks cute and our set
is so cute like maybe I'll try it it's
the best one and I'm also learning on
working they get right one oh the Sierra
one it's really good I want to learn
runagate I've learned the first half
it's so hard and it's like the longest
dance ever it's like a million steps
yeah I'm out that's where I drop in the
gate renegade
yeah that's just that's only part right
now yeah that's the only part that you
need to know okay let's get into the
first story because Kim and kinda things
you need to know Kim and Kanye are an
architectural digest with an
accompanying video that was just
fabulous we're getting photos of their
house that to me like when I first saw
photos of their house years ago I was
just like what are they doing but now
I'm like that survived I need that house
like I need the minimalism I can't look
at anything anymore no I totally I get
their vibe it's really not for me like I
love the Kardashian aesthetics I get to
actually happen to think all the girls
houses like that comfortable luxurious
like rich look is so cute and I like
that sort of aesthetic I don't love like
the minimalist I like it for them it's
not livable for me and it's like not my
personal style but I respect it and
they're very uh you know unlike also
like Andrew yang ahead of their time I
think they're so ahead of their time
like that's gonna be the new look right
now we're still going off with like
everything we see on HGTV but when Kim
was saying that decluttering her life
has made the biggest difference in she's
lays in her bed and she looks around it
so clean like she has it really helps
with her anxiety I literally wanted to
go into my bedroom and just wipe
everything off my beer yeah but it's
super easy like they don't how many
figurines and tchotchkes right now it's
like how many puck wrap butterflies do I
need it's like out of you it's easy
though for them to declutter when they
have a room for everything for the
clutter we're living in one in two
bedroom apartment I know I literally was
thinking I think I need to get rid of
this bureau it's just cluttering but
like where would I put all this no yeah
and they're like well you know cabinets
enclosing clothes and closets are toxic
so get cuz you have a room for your
clothes like of a room for your cabinets
right no it's just like it's no it's not
feasible I think I need to I need to
start just decluttering like that you
know if I got rid of a bunch of t-shirts
I wouldn't even notice no by the way I
bet totally and I think that I am like
ahead of my time as well because there's
nothing in my house like you will never
find if you're looking for something
like you left it on my house like it
automatically goes in the trash like you
have like a home me house yeah no but I
am like that I live have back wrap
butterflies too I have two and one of
them was a gift i but it's just like the
the Kim and Kanye would never have just
said it during sitting there yeah but no
but the only thing is what they were
talking about that I related to you was
like the the lack of
like material like just [ __ ] lying
around and I feel like I am very simple
sure I'm a simple girl with simple nice
base this the Chairman to put the things
away yes but I also don't live beyond
the space that I have I just like I need
to go into my house with like a vacuum
with a forklift
yeah and just get it out of there
totally I won't even realize it's like
when you know sometimes you don't you
don't find something for a while you
forgot that you even had it like oh you
didn't even miss it if you didn't even
know and that's how you know you can
live without it right so I guess I need
to get rid of my Bureau I just need to
get rid of all of my furniture that
video of them was super cute North came
in and was being an actual monster I
love her she is very eclectic and you
could tell like by the the parenting
vibe just by like that ten seconds she
was in the video like Connie obviously
like gives in to her like Dee Vanessa
Jim tries to like settle her down he's
mini Kanye yeah it must be like so
exciting for him to see this like young
this like small thing that's just a
miniature version of him yeah I think
that's the beauty of parenting in
general Kim looked beautiful
they were beautiful yeah they were being
so funny I was smiling the whole time if
you haven't watched a video go and watch
it like if you're not a Kim Kanye Stan
you might see I think it's quote-unquote
awkward but I just thought it was it was
so real so I actually am a Kim and
confident and I did think it was awkward
like it was a little weird and like I
get that that's like they're by but
she's like the funny one and he's like
the quiet one it was just it seemed a
little weird I thought it was hilarious
and we got to see their on the cup not
them but their house is on the cover of
Architectural Digest yeah and we got to
see North's bedroom we are getting sick
in it some sick photos of the house and
like the more I see of the house the
more I realize think it is more of a
home like I used to feel like they lived
in a spaceship yeah and now I'm just
like oh no they live in a very like
Marie Kondo home yeah it's entry
understand half the video because when
they were talking about like the true
Architectural Digest stuff like Claudio
and you know like yeah and literally had
no idea what they were talking about
like I respected the art you know yes
yes no and then talking about it like
that son I'm realizing like oh this this
is architectural drying right this isn't
cosmo no no this is not cosmo which
we'll be talking about we have lots to
discuss okay our next story i just thing
is such a sweet story i'm so excited to
share it because Sheryl Sandberg has
announced her engagement to
Bernthal okay usually we don't talk
about sure okay you should if you don't
talk about sheryl sandberg on the show
but she just got engaged and if you
remember a few years ago her husband
just uh died on a treadmill on a resort
in Mexico I don't remember that it was
very sad and now she has met someone
else who she was set up through her late
husband's brother oh no you think it's a
beautiful story that's nice wow I didn't
know that mm-hmm and Joe Sandberg is the
Facebook woman yes and she's leaning in
and she so works a Facebook um yes
she's CEO oh and she wrote that book
about leaning in yes and she she I kind
of make she started that whole thing
where like a woman is not bossy she's a
boss yeah and like you can have it all
if you lean in I just feel like I feel
like it's really easy you know for like
a woman whose salary is ten million
dollars to say that you can have it all
you know I just I don't know do you see
a lot of women who are in who have like
good jobs are really successful who seem
to say that you can't have it all so you
know the older I get and the more I
start thinking about like career and
kids I'm realizing it's very difficult
to have it all right and so Sheryl
Sandberg is helping you figure out how
to have it all again but she just has
resources beyond most people's means
that's what I'm saying yes but what I'm
saying is even people with those same
resources can't make it work sometimes
right so they should be so maybe you
can't have it all no but she's not even
a pet size no but not to be a pessimist
like you you might be able to have it
all I think that's just more realistic
for a book I know it's supposed to be
like a self-help and empowering book but
I just I prefer to be more realistic
like it's you you may be able to have it
all but you also may not be able to
maybe that's what she says in the book
maybe yeah we didn't read it yeah this
is just conjecture yes well this is the
morning conjecture yes but it looks like
she's having it all right now because
she captured a photo of them together on
social media saying engaged Tom Bernthal
you are my everything I could not love
you more that it's just so [ __ ] cute
considered really like the tragedy she's
been through so he was just on a
treadmill and like died mm-hmm did he
die from the fall on the treadmill cuz
it's dangerous to fall on the treadmill
um let me pull up the story for you
because it's so sad popular Silicon
Valley executive Dave Goldberg did not
die while exercising in Four Seasons
Resort in Mexico City up OH
so hmm it was reported that he had died
after
he fell off a treadmill and cracked his
head open oh [ __ ]
he had actually been exercising instead
inside a gym Oh at a different resort oh
ho but so he did die from the fall I
guess so
wow what a terrible way to die the
officials had told this story is
confusing oh I guess it's just one hotel
saying it wasn't their hotel it was a
different note about it oh I thought he
like you know had a heart attack and
then fell off the truck no he had a
heart attack that's what this is kind of
live you guys sorry about let me just go
this honestly sounds like an episode of
Blue Bloods like what was the real cause
of death you know what that was a theme
in the book that I just actually not a
theme just a smaller moment in the book
that I just finished well regardless of
how he died it's very sad he was the CEO
of SurveyMonkey that's a great platform
oh my god if one more person sends me a
Survey Monkey and we used to help me out
with my class project I'll bet you get
away from me he died due to severe head
trauma according to ABC News so that
could be from the fall yes that's
terrible terrible let's focus on the joy
here agree she's engaged it's so
wonderful and I'm happy for her and
that's why I decided to share the story
know that I decided to share else and
the story hit me with the next story
share Cheryl are you okay guys guys here
to take a pause Jackie's having a stroke
okay Cheryl what is going on it's just
drunk Jackie again but I go back and
listen to that Mike Piazza drugged
Jackie episode where we did like
telepathic podcasting when I was like in
Kansas or something and it remains to be
one of my favorite episodes telepathic
podcast you know what that's a good
segue into my next story that it just
shifted around Forbes has come out with
a list of the top five earning
podcasters and as podcaster stars helps
I think it is so interesting yeah no I I
didn't read through the top five are
because I want to be surprised and I
also want to guess I think I know a few
okay I don't think you're gonna be able
to guess
number one Joe Rogan yes he made thirty
million dollars last year there's hope
for us Jack to go for us a member by the
way there's hope for us but then it's
also like depressing because I think
we're the most successful podcast in the
world and hearing these numbers like
we're incredibly far away from being the
most successful but like I always think
oh my god our podcast is so big it
doesn't get any
but it's like oh no we have all this way
to grow that's true okay it's exciting
so I'm so excited about this number two
Marc Maron no my favorite murder was
killing Karen kill grass and Georgia
Hearts dark oh I know their their
artwork I've seen it on the yeah it's
always on the charts and this whole
article was kind of like a focus on them
they did like a profile about how their
podcast came to be they like minutes say
how these people make money any any
ideas um they pretty much talk about the
advertising um advertisers likely spent
close to 700 million dollars on podcast
in 2019 [ __ ] we gotta get a piece of
that pie it's a small little fraction no
according to shark tanks that's the
wrong way to think about your business
what do they say they say like if you
have to say this is it a 1 billion
dollar industry a year if we only got a
piece of that we'd be huge right that is
true that makeup is an 800 million
dollar a year industry they hate that
that's an automatic way to get out of
the tank and so that's just not how we
should be thinking as a business ok ok
number three you're never gonna find
Ferris no you don't even know this guy
the Dave Ramsey show jealous I don't
know him he made 10 million dollars last
year apparently he's a veteran radio
jock and his show is more like old
school radio format honestly it's just
not fair because like Joe Rogan and
growi Ramsey Rosa's him Ramsey
what's his a obtain Ramsey Dave Ramsey
like all these people are solo
podcasters we have to split our revenue
oh my favorite murder it's two girls
yeah they're two girls I'm so glad we
never had like a third co-host we just
split our money was totally CEO is gonna
be infringing total I mean he is my
favorite murder made 15 million dollars
the Dave Ramsey show me ten million
dollars number four amongst actually no
I think you like his podcast he's not
Conan O'Brien but he is a celeb
podcaster who do you think Dax Shepard
hopper am i that little [ __ ] getting how
much money nine million dollars last
year it's just not right number five do
I know them I don't think so it was a
Bill Simmons never heard of former I
don't know he and commentator about that
crazy at number five is a sports show
like yeah but I guess like sport like
it's like sports radio it's like ESPN
Radio I guess that kind of makes sense
yeah and I just want to use this
platform here to say like I would love
an extended list from Forbes like they
come out with the top 100 of everything
yeah I would just love to see where
everyone's at and also while we're
talking about podcasters to make money
subscribe to our patreon channel
patreon.com slash good morning toast
also support your local podcast convert
a toaster like just tell someone at your
office like who's having a bad day you
can't put a price on conversion to
listen to the toasts and I just feel
like we're in we're in a mode of like
acquiring new toasters and we'll start
making the show like with new toasters
in mind so they don't so they know what
the but they don't feel left behind
right exactly you don't want charged
make they also say like what's your
customer acquisition cost like what is
ours considering we've never spent a
dollar on advertising which I'd shark
tanks sometimes they're not keen to that
you know cuz it's like what are you
doing no and it's like spend a dollar
right no no it's like you're bad at your
business so technically our customer
acquisition cost is zero dollars
considering we never spent a dollar to
acquire a customer we need a billboard I
actually passed like a McDonald's that
had a huge billboard space available on
it and I wrote down the phone number cuz
I think a perfect place for us to
proselytize is on top of the McDonald's
no I think really those billboards
outside the Midtown Tunnel where you're
sitting in traffic and you just like
need something to distract you the
morning toast yeah that's where we need
a billboard but like those are the
expensive ones but not Midtown Tunnel
because also I don't think those people
would like us but you know much more
like a Holland Tunnel crowd exactly
exactly
okay next story so sweet Ashley Graham
and it is also podcasting news Ashley
grandma's injury introduced her new
Baumann guy that did not just refer to
Ashley Graham as a podcaster she's a
podcaster and not she talked about her
birth on her podcast which is why this
is podcast news desperate times for
Ashley Graham on to say the model gave
the world a first glimpse at her newborn
son who she and has been just in Irvine
welcomed on January 18th during a
heartwarming episode of her podcast
pretty big deal joined by urban the new
parents revealed that his name is Isaac
Menelik Giovanni Irvin and recalled the
day they welcomed their baby boy into
the world sorry mom Cass to me there's
only one Giovanni you know oh of course
you lambda Lesseps oh I was gonna say
Snooki's son oh I guess to me there's
only two Jo hobbies now there's three
its Giovanni
yeah but like Giovanni oh okay yeah
there is only one Giovanni and I'm
feeling it
you are yeah what was the story here
hey Graham oh yeah I'm at her and her
son's name is Isaac which is so biblical
yeah we met her at a concert and she was
pregnant and so lovely and just like
eating a funnel cake and that's just
what we want from our top models I
really like her I really like her too
I'm really happy for her and her podcast
you know so really with your face for
everyone there is fate that's true we're
joking and there is space for everyone
and speaking of things that I like you
know what else I like what are you gonna
tell me do you have a guess um honey yes
Jackie I do honey is the free online
shopping tool that automatically finds
the best promo codes and applies them to
your card and you know how great it
feels how does it feel to save with
honey saving feels like sliding into a
seat on the train just before the doors
close I don't take the train but I
imagine that that's what it feels like I
actually found out about honey from the
toasters I've been using it before they
started paying us to say like flagging
down your uber before it starts to drive
away no saving it feels like tentative
okay because there's no better feeling
than that honey has found over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings did you know honey supports
over 30,000 stores including Macy's
Target Sephora Best Buy and more users
love honey including us and that's why
it has over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on the google chrome store oh
the best part is that it's free so you
install the extension installs in just a
few seconds get honey for free at join
honey calm slash toast that's join honey
calm slash toast wait what was that
join honey calm slash just sign on save
money what else
okay this and final story in a nice
segue into our bachelor recap Cosmo has
pulled its bachelor cover after Victoria
fuller modeled clothing with quote white
lives matter slogan so it is okay by the
way we're going straight into bachelor
recap so if you haven't watched just
mute us for a second yeah okay this show
is a piece of trash like it there comes
a point in every season where you get so
fed up with like the lack of respect
that the network has for your time and
your intelligence and for me that was
last night they released a statement via
Chris Harrison's Twitter that the
episode was going to be three hours long
because the Iowa caucus was happening in
ABC News was gonna interrupt
and so they formatted it for three hours
to make time for those adjustments right
um there was not one interruption from
ABC News for the Iowa caucus I'm not
complaining
but all I'm saying is that they had
three hours in contact and if there were
interruptions it would have been four
hours is what you're saying right like
it was supposed to go over I think so
crazy
it wasn't beyond a regular episode like
it was nothing crazy happened like it
was just if it was a two-hour episode it
would have been a fine episode as a
three-hour episode it was a piece of
trash yeah it was a fine episode
compared to the past episodes cuz at
least I don't know I felt like certain
ways about certain people whereas before
I'm like who are these [ __ ] like I
don't care that they're fighting let's
take it from the top but the news that's
circulating today because they did this
Cosmo shoot as one of the challenges and
I just like a cute challenge like that I
thought it was so cringy and the fact
that she I think the problem is actually
even one when like her sitting there
making out with him with the other girl
Tara was in cute content no also like
Cosmo is allegedly a fashion magazine
and those bathing suits were straight
out of the garbage like so tacky looked
like we were at the Hard Rock Hotel in
Vegas like so nasty sorry I said it
yeah no I wasn't here for the shoot at
all but I thought the idea of like the
winner getting by the way and they said
cover and then in their article follow
up they said it was gonna be a digital
cover so none of these [ __ ] were ever
actually gonna be on the cover of
Cosmopolitan and here once again ABC
network taking advantage of our time but
most importantly our intelligence yes so
Cosmo released a statement saying that
they weren't gonna publish this digital
cover the editor-in-chief wrote on
Monday that quote it wasn't until a few
weeks ago that I found out that the
woman I'd chosen had in her past modeled
in an ad campaign wearing white lives
matter attire it's worth noting that the
white lives matter organization has
nothing to do with like white people
it's about white fish white marlin white
Marlins but again the sentiment is off
and that's why they cancelled it but
it's worth noting that it's not like a
political affiliation organization not
specifically yes but you know what I'm
not mad because I literally hate
Victoria fuller and I'm just like so
happy for all the negative things that
are happening to her reality Steve said
that and I've been trying like to avoid
reality see but there's so much good
stuff and this is not a spoiler but
reality Steve said that he's never had a
contestant come on and have so many
people reach out to him saying such
negative things about her really yeah
like it was historic I know you you hate
her I do she's she's just confusing to
me cuz I hate like her hiding behind her
shyness and then like no see again so
again okay the challenge the first
challenge that she got was a revolve
fashion show oh I'm so shy and then
she's like showing her titties on the
runway and she
in second place right so like then again
photoshoot no I'm so shy no no no and
then she wins and she's making out with
him wearing a beanie like I just can't
she's not shy I will die on the hill of
saying that this girl's lying about her
insecurities I don't know that's me to
say but she's lying and she ruins it for
like actually shy people that's what I'm
saying you know like I'm a shy person
and I gotta feel represented by her and
those bathing suits like just walking
around like McKenna with like her cutout
triangle bathing suit like it was just
the epitome of sadness like this date
was horrible you know was there it was
the epitome of nothing of the sort
oh and Hannah Ann like not winning the
modeling date like I thought she was
actually going to like pull her brain I
know and you know the shot I actually
really liked the redhead who was sent
home Lexi with her vagina suit yeah Ana
Tasha me too they did a pair I thought
they looked fabulous I saw that too and
I did think it was like a very high
fashion America's next top model' moment
he should've won
I completely agree but they worried they
could have done a cover shoot with the
two of them like flanking Peter like oh
and it could have been like a Betty and
Veronica Archie and then the and if they
had won I'm available for hire Jackie if
they have won that they would have won
they would have actually been on the
cover right Paige you know it's obvious
you know that the editor-in-chief of
Cosmo needs to be fired because she has
terrible taste in models no offense like
she chose Victoria like to me none of
the girls really stood out especially
Victoria no she did the cringy a thing
yeah and that's how you saw her
personality I'm like the most obvious
thing you know yeah so I thought she was
gonna choose I'm Tammy because we
actually saw Tammy's personality when
she kissing behind her and she made that
face and I was like oh there's some
personnel and by the way they keep using
that photo like on Instagram and
promoting all their articles about it so
they obviously liked that photo I
totally thought she was gonna win me -
no I'm glad that she didn't because she
is nothing of the sort
and I will get there okay right so
before that Alya came back and got sent
home which really cemented for me that
Peter sucks
he's very indecisive he's the worst
person on the show and I actually think
the whole season is bad not only because
these girls suck but really because
Peter sucks he doesn't know what to do
when he wants to make these decisive
decisions but he does it in a way where
like he doesn't have enough information
and I saw it like him giving Kelsey a
rose oh my god putting the target on her
back putting a target on her back
sending her to the wolves and on top of
that canceling the cocktail party and
making it seem like that was because of
her right but I loved when he canceled
the cocktail party and
turn down me like I love that they
started turning on Kelsey dad you know
and also this is like the meanest bunch
of girls we've seen in a long time and
what's crazy is that it's 20/20 and like
we're no longer being mean to be Jackie
I completely agree and you know who
really started that mean girl crew tabby
should know they're all turning around
like living for it no I'm so not here
for timing to me she's the worst kind of
girl and like I like Kelsey what's her
problem that she cares no it's like she
took adderall in birth control like
she's so doable
everything that her comes out of her
mouth is iconic totally and by the way
this happens every season where someone
like has a breakdown about the fact that
the guy they like is dating 12 other
girls which is a very normal emotion to
have and they're all acting like she's
so crazy
that's normal sorry she likes Peter
Tammy he's never even spoken to him
right and there are so many other girls
there who whose intentions are so clear
and Kelly is a star a star she's a star
she's way too good for Peter and she
doesn't need to be there but I'm not
ready for her to go home yet no but
their date was cringy because like he's
being so hard on her for not giving 100%
when it's like you literally spoken to
her three times for dating 12 other
girls and you're mad at her for not
giving hundred percent yeah and like she
was saying like me and totally yes you
are Hannah and is revolving around the
world and Kelly is an attorney and she
wants to get married and she's in her
30s like not one is not better than the
other they're just different right so
she really came on the show for the
right thing and she thought back to what
Peter was doing to you but now I was
getting so caught up in all this
[ __ ] it's making her things like
maybe he's not here like for an attorney
who's in her 30s who's ready to like
settle down and have kids right and even
after she gave him like clear examples
of that obviously she came with her yeah
evidentiary support when he was like
okay aside from Hannah and like what
else and she was like rewarding the
drama no she's she had this conversation
in her head 500 times before she
actually added with Peter because she's
been like stewing on the airplane I just
love her like she is everything over the
store and we know that she's a toaster
and it makes it better it makes it even
better
and that's not why I love her no no of
course not and then the my Kenna at the
end of the episode just being absolutely
out of control with her tongue just like
running around town being all upset that
the cocktail party got cancelled like as
if that was gonna save her like I hope
the whole premise of the episode which
was like all these irrelevant girls like
making a stink it's just so frustrating
to spend airtime on people like crying
who are completely irrelevant like in no
in no way does my kind of think that
she's winning this or that she
even has a legitimate connection with
Peter like she looks around at the other
girls it's not even not even a
competition yeah and when anyone who's
crying who hasn't had a one-on-one and
like hasn't had a real relationship
they're crying because they're gonna be
kicked off of television not hip
followers and like to me that's a red
flag Peter so crazy where'd the red
flags I get up mining them and then
dumping people that's the red flag and I
think it's worth mentioning that Hannah
Anne has never had a one-on-one she gets
one next week but what I'm saying is
that she's technically in the same boat
as McKenna and lexico but they had that
initial connection exactly they they're
meant for each other and Hannah and my
chemists not oh right and huh and we
don't see Hannah and crying all the time
right no Hannah and has had the same
advantages as Lexi and McKenna and Tammy
and she's made more of it because they
actually have a connection yeah I think
Lexi was crying because she made some
good friendship
yeah no all the girls were crying when
Lexi left I was like I started to get
sad too because like she went up I mean
she didn't go up again she got robbed
but she side kicked when Sydney went up
against hammy and yes need a sidekick
yeah and I want to talk about Sydney who
started out as one of my favorite people
and now I'm 100% sure she's the meanest
girl in the house
she's starting all this drama she's
always in the middle of it she was on
the wrong side of a lie or her in
Victoria P like running around the house
like they run this [ __ ] when Victoria P
is not to be trusted the two of them are
like this mean girl crew were like they
got Tammy and Bob but then they turned
on her they were just like starting this
like nasty mean girl crew and I've been
reading some stuff about Sydney like in
her real life you know she went to the
same high school as Hannah brown yeah
and did she say that she at lunch in the
bathroom or is that what people are
saying that's what she said and then
someone who was at her high school
literally tweeted pictures of their
yearbook being like she's one of the
most popular girls right and then she
replied being like you can be win a
beauty pageant and still be bullied so I
don't want to discredit the fact like
maybe people were like me and my sister
because it's very possible but like the
evidence is showing that like that's not
the case when people who are at a high
school said she was like literally
Regina George like she was so mean to
everyone and like the most popular girl
in school okay because she's really
pretty
no but she's so she's so pretty and I
liked her in the beginning but like she
in the house she's responsible for all
the drama and she's one of the meanest
girls there okay I said it okay I hear
you I see that but I like her because
one like she's pretty too her
conversation with Peter was very easy
and she could like hold a conversation
when he told her that she was the best
kisser in the house I was like so weird
so I compared kissing yeah that was
really very inappropriate he's like you
need to remind her that he's
in 15 other girls right I totally agree
and three like I really did like how she
shut that [ __ ] down with Tami and maybe
like that's because she's a mean girl so
she knows how to do that and by created
Chad offended my girl Kelsie yeah but
she just she didn't care about being on
the right side
someone came for her like she created
the monster that was Tammy and then to
her job anyone South Loop like it was so
iconic Tammy it's a joke and literally
the episode ending with the last two
rows is going to Tammy and my Kenna
that's when I was done three hours of my
time just to be stuck with these two
morons
those were the nothing of the sort roses
nothing of the store and I've been
telling you guys since day one that my
kennel was nothing of the sort and
you're seeing it and the tongue oh wait
the tongue but also the fake crying she
literally was crying the whole episode
she wasn't actually crying
she was crying except when she went to
Peter - like yeah - and she wasn't
crying that's your biggest fear yeah her
not and then by the end Natasha said the
same thing yeah but when Natasha said it
was fine because she's smart
no and Natasha she's something I'm the
sorta Natasha's everything of the sort
she is okay well even Natasha's friends
to Sydney you have to look at it that
way but you know Tasha by the way I like
her but in the last couple of fights
she's been on the wrong side of history
she was against Alya
and then she was against Kelsey but then
she shut her mouth when everyone
realized Kelsey was totally right Kelsey
was totally right there's nothing wrong
with crying four hours a day they have
nothing better to do right oh and then
having she's an alcoholic Tami is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's such a [ __ ] and
then the pill popping I was like where
do they even get pills right its birth
control like think thank you for being
safe the producers take their medication
and like dole it out like that you are
at camp
uhm they do I'm pretty sure you don't
just get to like have a bottle of pills
like the infirmary yeah I'm pretty sure
at least that's what it's like on unreal
Oh
on unreal interesting well we have to
cut that short because we are coming up
with a very exciting segment with my
friend Simon Huck who is here to tell us
everything we need to know about
everything including his new company
Judy so we're gonna take a quick break
and bring him out and our segment with
Simon Thank You Simon it's brought to
you by first leaf saving money on
award-winning wine you're guaranteed to
love has never been easier than it is
with first leaf
unlike other wine clubs that guess about
your favorite wines firstly fuses your
feedback and ratings to carry wine
selections personalized for your your
unique
firstly the so confident in the quality
of their wine they even have a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed that
means if you're not feeling a particular
bottle of wine first leaf will
completely cover it we got started by
taking the first leaf wine quiz to
assess our exact wine drinking
preferences from sweetness to wine
styles to even how adventurous I am they
learned all about what we like firstly
then created an introductory 6-pack of
wine for us all at just $29.95 seriously
an introductory pack of wine for just
under 30 dollars these bottles of wine
will normally go for $20 apiece they
send out more than 17 thousand unique
shipments of wine every month because
everyone's tastes are so different try
first leaf wine club today we're buying
great wine is simple sign up with our
link and you'll get an exclusive intro
first six bottles of wine for only
$29.95 plus free shipping just go to try
first leaf dot-com slash toast that's
six bottles of wine for only $29.95 plus
free shipping try first live.com slash
toast in the comfort of your own home
we're going to take a quick break and be
back with simon huck if you have
questions for him and you're watching
live on youtube please feel free to
inundate our stream with questions for
him we don't care how inappropriate we
will see you back in a few minutes go
get a snack
we are back with someone who I cannot
believe has never been on this show it's
a travesty and I'm very upset about it
but he's here making it right
Simon Huck hello I don't even know what
to introduce you as now cuz you're like
an entrepreneur now I mean I think you
can call me entrepreneur Spin Master
lifeguard yeah lifeguard star of the
spin crowd star has been caught oh my
god that's what I choose to well that's
how we met yeah Claudia
slid into my DM big fence winner had on
Twitter really erm wasn't around then
you're right sure sure I was like thank
you so much by the way that was an
iconic show and probably the number one
question we got for you we have so much
to cover and we will but the number one
question we got for you was will he ever
get a spin crowd season two we're not
gonna get a spin card season two but
it's just because Jonathan went on to do
more food-related right influenced their
work and truthfully I don't think I was
meant to be on like a docudrama show
about your on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians I am on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians but the PR show was so
focused on our client and none of our
clients wanted to be on it so it was
like one of those hard things oh yeah
how can you produce a segment when no
one wants to be on it yeah we ended up
doing things unlike the Candy Company
Sugar Factory Oh cuz the thirstiest
company alive yeah they do a job but
they're killing it no no it's a real
business and speaking of killing it in
real businesses you just launched your
own company well you have your own
company you now own all by yourself
command PR which was the company yep on
this big crowd you have been killing it
for years so it's an entertainment
marketing company and in a nutshell we
connect brands with celebrities so when
you're watching a Superbowl commercial
and you see like lalala hawking shampoo
I am the agency that put the celebrity
in the spot got it there's the
misconception around me representing
talent or me representing the
Kardashians and I do not represent
people you're just friends with them
yeah exactly some of these people along
the way when we first you know became
friends they were not famous and now
obviously over 15 years some of them
have become huge stars what was your
favorite Super Bowl commercial this year
oh yeah that's a great question I love
the Google one didn't feel ready I
didn't like it I liked it I thought it
was like really cringey and like trying
so hard to make us cry like oh I was
just oh I did not I didn't cry cuz you
guys would have made fun of me
thought it was really well done Oh
cringe mercy and John's did you like it
no it was a waste of Chrissy and John I
thought like it was great because there
and in like they looked great
but oh I like the car though they were
trying so hard in the beginning of the
commercial to make their slogan like
make sense young man jury yeah and I was
like what's coming on here then it's
some pretty car showed up and they made
the joke about sexiest man alive and
that part was funny yeah what worked is
all I can think about is the genesis
though and you just got engaged and I
got engaged I cannot believe that you
got engaged when I met you I was like
you're never getting married like I just
never gave me that vibe always the bride
yet yeah no always about yeah I was
right thank you but now you're getting
married
now I'm getting married how that when so
we're not sure we're gonna get married I
would say in a year and a half and I
think in LA to eliminate some of my
family and some of his dead okay like a
smaller group and yeah it was really a
very unexpected thing but I knew I was
launching Judy and the fear for me was I
launched this company and Phil would
turn on me my fiancee would turn on me
at the time boyfriend so I decided just
to get it out of the way I know that
does not sound romantic but literally on
Tuesday I was like okay we're doing that
like I just psyched myself into it in
order to do it cuz I knew once I popped
the question it would be so much like
planning who's coming what are you doing
what are you wearing who's the bride
who's the groom who's the bride yeah
obviously fail yeah no she's already
become bridezilla oh really
out of control that's great yeah keep
interesting no it's less it's more
logistics like how many bachelor parties
is appropriate should we do
international business your way joint
it's a great question I think the same
friend group we do but then we we also
have like different kind of pockets I
think we'll do one with everyone and
then we'll both do individuals oh wow
yeah yeah where do you wanna go I think
we'll do one in Montauk which you guys
will come to done done hosting and then
we'll do one maybe international like
I'd love to go to Paris like get a
picture in from the Eiffel Tower like
really do it you know peih-gee says that
one was underrated about red spots
the world is Montreal oh no but I'm
Canadian I love my troll it's beautiful
but yeah I feel like I really that's not
special
it's not special it's an hour and a half
from like where I grew up I always
forget that you're coming ya know it's
wild I survived I just became an
American citizen three more oh yes
welcome to America it was so people
don't realize how difficult is to
actually move here and enjoy your
citizenship here forever yeah it took me
15 years to go do I never work yeah
shucks now you're one of us because I
started 2004 I stir imove here to work
for Lizzie Grubman and Jonathan that's
when they had a business together I
think the number one question we got for
you also is are you in charge and still
friends so we're still friends we don't
see each other as much as we used to but
I love him I mean Jonathan was 10 years
of my life right like he also you know I
don't know if he's like love to talk
about this but he was one of the best
publicists
one of the best marketers one of the
best branders I've ever met in my life
he taught me so much I think what
happened is we did this thing crowd I
didn't necessarily love the idea of
having a TV show but our business he did
he got the itch yes the minute we did
that show it was liked by Jonathan
Wright welcome food guy
right like years later he developed this
brand and he's so pout you so good at it
it just wasn't it wasn't gonna work no
yeah but still still under terms still
in good terms yeah we haven't turned on
each other so tell me how's someone who
you know is a regular on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians travels around the world
goes on yachts with everyone is a PR
maven marketing maven ends up creating
Judi okay great we don't you know the
genesis of who is Judi who is Judi we're
all Judy's yeah so Judi is something
over the past five years we have had so
many friends who've been in emergency
situations
I have friends who've lost their homes
in the fires in California I friends in
Florida who've had storm surges been in
hurricanes and the same question they
always ask is like why was I not
prepared like what stopped me from being
prepared so my co-founder and I Josh
we've spent the last year-and-a-half
researching what are the brands out
there that are keeping families prepared
for merchants we looked at the Red Cross
which is an incredible or
but doesn't do a good job of keeping us
prepared so we started developing Judy a
year and a half ago and spoke to so many
people we have some of the best experts
in preparedness helping us curate
exactly what's going on in the kit so
it's something we're super excited about
this one that we have here is the
biggest and most expensive this is like
the appliance of preparedness and it's
like the mothership this is 250 and this
is not that much money life saving right
cleaning could charge like a thousand
dollars well if we wanted it for to be
for everyone yeah yeah so it starts at
$60 it goes to 250 this is for a family
of four up to three days and it has
absolutely everything you could need
over 36 different items inside the case
so you're meant to just like leave this
in your closet somewhere
you're meant to leave it in your closet
but you're also meant to unpack it it
has a first-aid it has a flashlight
yeah and they get familiar with what's
in there right and the number one thing
that separates duty from other emergency
kits is you have to make a plan so
education and knowledge is the biggest
piece of Judy so it's not just good
enough that you bought the kit you have
to actually talk to your family talk to
your friends make a plan make a plan
make a plan we're like have you ever
figured out how to evacuate from your
apartment before yeah take the elevator
take the elevator yeah so those are
Judy's all about it's all about making a
plan that's so crazy so important I feel
like especially in this day and age like
it's the peace of mind that comes with
owning something like this but you know
we live in a very like scary time right
now it's so scary with coronavirus right
now I mean we just got off the phone
with all of our suppliers in China and
they're freaking out I mean oh we air
mass are backordered for six weeks on
Amazon to Amazon even they're like the
shitty one yeah but you have masks in
there there are air masks in here there
are safety goggles there's gloves
there's hand sanitizer I mean a lot of
people don't realize that hand sanitizer
is not created equal so your hand
sanitizer needs to 60% alcohol and above
an order for it to be effective huh so
these are all the tips that you just
gonna send you and we send it to you via
text message right I thought the whole
system is connected via text so Jackie
had a question of what do I do in the
event of a like a household fire Judy
would respond to you with real-time tips
so what type of emergencies is the kit
built for emergencies bacon small
scrapes and bruises in the playground or
these high consequence events with
everything which is like fire
nuclear war yeah like anything from
floods to wildfires to household fires
everything earthquakes so I got the mini
fanny pack and there was like a little
food thing in there I can't explain to
how they make the food so small but it's
like a meal it's a meal it's a 400
calorie meal replacement bar and it's
shelf stable for five years which means
you can throw that in your cupboard and
it will still be delicious in five years
delicious but you could eat it while I
was like gonna eat didn't open it and
I'm like and you know three years is me
some emergency my fat ass ate the bar
I've been eating the bar constantly judy
judy judy headquarters judy HQ Judy HQ
we're on fire over there that's iconic
yeah and I'm sure just because the you
know the current climate is really kind
of wild these are selling like hotcakes
this it's been insane like the last
seven days has been like we've been
barely sleeping just 24/7 and Judy
office it's great their reaction from
families across the country he's been so
positive a lot of people have reached
out and said like this we've been
through in an emergency we were not
prepared thank you for creating a
product that makes sense to us right and
it's a cute branding like from a shark
tank perspective where big shark tank
watchers yeah well obviously we do great
I don't do great I don't think you need
it no we've already like you have the
backer we birthday yeah yeah the reason
why it's so that other people could like
watch it and get an order Judy to get
ABC like 50% you know it's a whole it's
also like I don't know if I'm strong
enough mentally to go through that I
don't like they say no to my investment
I would literally attack it's like
literally your child yeah and they're so
mean on their their ages - oh yeah oh
but I think I actually think you would
do great we do we've done deals in my
marketing company with Barbara Corcoran
actually all of them they all love deals
I mean well so you work with celebrities
all the time yeah like aside from the
obvious like Kim it's just that's like
who has been the most lovely surprising
person to work with
like that's just easy doesn't have a
million people so I'm doing a deal right
now with Kelly Ripa and she's absolutely
lovely really yeah just the sweetest
kindest person I'll say it's never the
celebrity that's the nightmare
it's the agent always you know this yeah
you're so my agent the manager who's on
or the publicist out of control who's on
the message training call and screaming
and
you know and Pete like having PTSD I'm
like can you stop scream like it's never
this the talent the talent is thrilled
to work yeah yeah do you in some ways
feel like you are not an official
capacity but like a representative for
the Kardashian family like people are
always asking you stuff I think what
happens because I'm in PR and marketing
people assume that I represent them
right so it's a lot of misinformation so
I'm constantly being like I don't
represent them like the Kaiser the
Khazar my friends they're not know but
like even in your personal circles like
do people like whenever I have a
question I just ask you about them like
hey what's going on here yeah I mean I
don't watch the show as regular as I
should sometimes I am on it you're
Ceaser iconic like a look-alike no I
mean it's it's like a lot of deflecting
of people asking I don't always watch
the show the girls obviously have this
incredible life and what's crazy is like
I filmed other reality shows like they
live and breathe like the camera being
there or the camera not being there it's
the exact same
unlike other shows where you're like oh
this is a storyline right the girls just
have grown up with cameras for over a
decade they're living their life very
authentically and that's why the show is
now taking such an interesting turn with
Kourtney not wanting to be on it anymore
right right drama okay I want to take
some questions from Instagram this is a
great question from Kerouac ler did you
have anything to do with Kanye's camp
reaching out to us to stay in close on
Sunday
nothing yeah didn't even know didn't
even know that was a thing yeah I saw it
on your Instagram but like was so
excited for you are you sure the way
that it happened cuz it was seemed
organic most at musicom I don't know oh
I don't know your zeitgeist you're like
you're the pulse of the moment iconic
that was sold-out theater shaking Simon
was there you guys know Lee was I there
but I was like frozen with just
excitement and I was so proud proud
parent did the toasters like love you
and attack you yeah they were like oh
hey Mario like they were like okay they
looked at me but they were not like they
were fine know your iconic whenever I
leave anywhere with Simon and like out
in New York everyone knows him everyone
stick picture with him like a thief oh
oh good god you really downplay who like
he's a man about town um hold on Ostrom
see with therapy you have recently under
quite the transformation physically let
me see saw you on season one the spin
zone you were wearing glasses the spin
crowd you were a lot thinner
yes wore glasses but you are small F now
so it was a four year renovation that we
did talk to bottom so the first thing
was food I needed to start eating more I
was a candy junkie like gummy worms all
day long so found a trainer found a
woman that helped me like put together
like a food program you know did a few
tweaks you know so what's your diet like
now oh like 15 chickens a day it's like
a car that you have to do I love chicken
yeah chickens great but I'm so tired of
it it's the best chicken in the city
according to you I love sweet green you
I'm sorry to be a bit yeah but I love
sweet cream since you are man about town
what do you think is what like give me
three of the best restaurants in New
York right now okay I love catch I know
I'm gonna get roasted for this our
catches people jam me all around town
because I constantly go there but I love
the 14th and I'll go to catch steak yeah
I like it's different it depends what
kind of net you're trying to have like
you go to you go to catch with like
you're with your boyfriend and then you
go to like catch steak with your sugar
daddy yeah exactly I love st. Ambrose
like a block from my apartment great one
we loved on Angie which is like what is
that John Angie's thirty feet from my
apartment and it's absolutely delicious
it's an Italian recipe yeah it's easy
yeah and so you also just had not also
recently like maybe a few years got a
beautiful house in Montauk and you're
like a man about town in Montauk as well
I consider myself yes it's quasi mayor
yeah do you feel like it honestly like
when I think of socialites like it's not
really thing anymore like Tinsley
Mortimer but you really feel like the
closest thing to a socialite to me oh my
god you're so generous and what's that
like like I would just love that like
well I don't consider myself as socially
but I would say in Montauk because I
bring like 15 to 20 gay men each weekend
do I like really burn it down I actually
have a reputation out there of like what
guys you have staying at your I'm like
excuse me this is not a broth
these are my friends who happen to be
shirtless who are very good-looking well
and they love to post on Instagram so I
get this reputation meanwhile Phil and I
are like conservative bearers right yeah
what people don't know is that you don't
leave your house I do I'm a shut-in
yeah me and I went to dinner recently
literally at 6 o'clock and we were in
bed by 7:30 we negotiated versus the
clock we would have got it for ya right
now I'm the same way but it's like you
just you know such an exciting life and
then people would be shocked to find
that like you literally are a home
person well I think it's like you feel
and I'm sure you guys feel this way too
you feel like when you do something
special and exciting you should post on
Instagram just so you're like I did it I
did it and then I go back to kind of the
nine-to-five of like I'm staying indoors
right yeah and working on Judi you only
leave your house now for things that
make you money yeah I feel that
um this from Andrew James John Jay P G
what is the best professional advice
you've ever been given maybe from Kris
Jenner no I doubt it
early on from someone in Canada who told
me get an unpaid internship yeah for
your services for free and don't expect
anything and I listened and I picked up
the phone when I was 19 20 years old and
I called Lizzie gruben's office I was
like I'll work for free I have no money
I was like I'll work for free I'll do
whatever it takes and I moved and that
started my career literally a phone call
and I had seen us we weekly and there
was a picture of Lizzie in and that's
how I I didn't even know what PR what I
thought PR was event-planning I thought
I would be like handing out flyers in
the street I didn't know I thought it
was like guerilla marketing yeah I had
no a PR in Canada doesn't exist in
history I mean it does but not in the
way that I thought it did as a Canadian
what are your thoughts on Megan Marco
making a grand return I think it's
incredible I think then I think Megan
was suffering in London the London press
brutalized her I know you're are you not
a fan uh I just don't believe it you
know it's like you go to London and
everyday you wake up you have no friends
over there you want to show you your
mom's not there that's true and the
London press brutalized her every day
she couldn't do one thing right yeah so
like what do you do do you like just
suck it up and live this life or do you
move to Canada which is part of the
Commonwealth hello and so it's still
part of the monarch
and you live a lovely life with you know
your husband and your child and your
friends and you can make money yeah
right yeah yeah that is if she moves if
they move to Canada so as as one of the
the biggest talent buyers in the country
obviously our agency was flooded with in
Greece for Megan we received I can't
tell you how many offers the first week
like seven figures Oh huge really equity
offers oh yeah Shh I mean she's not
taking any office right now but it was
unbelievable in your opinion in her
first working year whenever that's gonna
make me next year how much one do you
think she can make if she really did it
all if she did it all she would make a
hundred million dollars stop but she
won't lose not gonna do come like
traditional commercial endorsements
she's not gonna be doing a perfume
she'll do things with like a quippy or a
Netflix perfume would be good for her
though seeing her all over duty-free I
think that optically she just can't do a
commercial endorsement at this stage
even if it was like Chanel I think that
she would get the the look of it would
be I agree she'll have to be they'll
have to be a judge it's almost like what
Michelle and Barack are doing like the
type of endorsements yes follow in that
path yes you'll do a book deal she'll do
a speaking yes yeah um last question for
you was from Liz Hyatt how did you and
your fiance meet oh he'll kill me for
saying this we met on tinder
oh yeah it's a modern way all the way
well I was swiping at in my district he
was in Long Island okay he lives in
Smithtown and I was like you know what
I'm gonna treat myself and get the past
eight to seven ninety-nine
when is swiping and I found this
incredible person who was so nice so
cute and we had our first date we went
to catch and I returned a story and he
interrupts and he was like do you know
you ordered for me yeah you didn't which
I'm not even a person who would ever do
that you don't like I spoke for him when
the waiter came out oh wow probably just
cuz you go to catch so much like right
when you would kill for the spicy tuna
right you're a man about town like I
said yeah yeah that's iconic so where
can people get judy judy out ready judy
calm oh and why is she Judy so Judy is
we tested a hundred names I wish we had
a fancy answer for this but we don't we
tested a hundred names and this is the
name that resonated the most everyone
knew a Judy in the
like they're reliable right she was not
reliable she was not a girl like that's
actually such a good point and I
appreciate the honesty
right okay you couldn't do like a
canvass no she's no Jimmy like Judy
feels like someone you can depend on
right like a reliable grandmother a
reliable aunt a safe place a safe place
one of the other names in contention oh
my god we had Casey we talked about
Casey oh my god not rely on our reliable
reliable ReadySet Casey yeah no no um
okay Judy it is so ready Judy and then
follow Instagram at ready set so ready
that you need exactly it's such a good
name everyone needs one $250 is not a
lot and that's for the biggest boy
there's other versions succeeded too if
you play the fanny packs how much are
the fanny packs $60 Timmy
you just go to the 250 treat yourself
honestly this is giving you the peace of
mind and it's for a family of four up to
up to three days of supplies it's a dog
food in there there isn't but we're
coming in with the dog cat I will be the
first person purchasing yeah absolutely
right I mean yeah and make sure to
follow at Simon Huck on Instagram for
updates on all things being a man about
town you should change your Instagram to
at man-about-town
god I love you my couple says I love you
thank you so much for listening to the
morning show some money a morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up and leave a comment if you
want we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasting me down so that's
about if I iTunes stitcher public radio
I Heart Radio cashbox
wherever you choose to listen to podcast
maybe you know subscribe to our podcast
and Li the beautiful review may be five
stars about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are and how we have such great
guests maybe if you want you just a
suggestion thank you so much we will see
you tomorrow with Reza Farahan from
Shahs of Sunset